46 ans après ils retrouvent leurs terres
ces agriculteurs palestiniens basés à
l'origine près de barr dallas en
cisjordanie avait vu jusque là leurs
territoires occupés par des colons un
retour à la ferme pour ses hommes
quatre ans après le verdict d'un
tribunal israélien ordonnant la
restitution de ces terres à leurs
propriétaires après une longue attente
les fermiers savoure cette décision un
sentiment indescriptible nos terres ont
été confisquées en 1973 ou 1971 par des
colons on n'y a pas eu accès pendant
cette période
un sentiment indescriptible cette aire
qui a été confisqué et cultivée par
l'occupation israélienne et les colons
et dont l'accès nous était auparavant
interdits pour que les fermiers puissent
de nouveau cultiver leurs terres les
tracteurs agricoles ont de nouveau été
autorisés une autorisation validé par
l'autorité générale des affaires civiles
le conseil de barda là ainsi que le
gouvernorat notre terre et dans la
plaine de kahône au nom des pères et des
grands parents qui se sont vu refuser
l'accès à cette terre et pour les
israéliens qui disent que les adultes
meurent et que les petits oublis à nous
n'avons pas oublié
nous continuerons et préserveront cette
leçon pour nos enfants
jusqu'à ce que le dernier maître de
palestine soit libéré si dieu le veut
la vallée du jourdain qui couvre un
quart de la cisjordanie est considéré
comme une terre particulièrement fertile
60% des légumes consommés par la
population locale sont cultivés dans
cette zone israël considère la vallée du
jourdain comme une zone tampon de
sécurité le premier ministre netanyahu a
répété à plusieurs reprises son souhait
d'annexer cette région stratégique